und wir schauen nach bayern tatort ece
ein mann geht plötzlich auf 4 zug
reisende los mit einem messer einem
klappmesser mit einer acht zentimeter
klinge er verletzt die männer im ece am
kopf und an der brust und er ein
flüchtling der 2014 nach deutschland
gekommen war er wird zum glück
festgenommen im zug er noch schlimmeres
passiert die helden eine junge
bundespolizistin die privat in dem zug
unterwegs war ja hier spielte sich diese
tat am samstag ab in bayern im ic von
passau nach würzburg auf offener strecke
im wagen fünf dieses in cee
passagiere hatten da einen notruf
abgesetzt der lokführer der hat dann den
zug gestoppt in dem kleinen bahnhof von
seibersdorf wir haben das gerade gesehen
dort auf der karte da haben dann
polizisten den ece gestürmt um den
messer angreifer eben festzunehmen das
also in diesem fall die endstation
dieses messerangriffs was wissen wir
über den täter er soll unzufrieden nie
leiden also psychisch krank sein das
sagt der leitende staatsanwalt der rat
neuhof und ernannte in einer
pressekonferenz weitere details
die polizei schicke männer die ihm
beobachten würden die gegen ihn seien
die kämen um ihn verrückt zu machen das
hat keinerlei realen hintergrund es
laufen und liefen keinerlei polizeiliche
maßnahmen gegen den beschuldigten
zur tat selbst hat er angegeben er habe
sich von vom ersten opfer bedroht
gefühlt er sei der meinung gewesen
dieser mann wollte ihn töten
und habe ihn deshalb angegriffen
die anderen partien habe er wie im traum
gegangen er hat die taten also nicht
abgestritten ja diese tat vom samstag
die hat uns alle sofort erinnert an
diesen axt angriff 216 war das in der
regionalbahn bei würzburg geben da ganz
in der nähe damals verletzte ein
17-jähriger flüchtlingen fünf menschen
schwer der täter wurde damals von der
polizei erschossen der angriff damals
der war anschließend eingestuft worden
als islamistisch motivierte terrortat
wir schauen noch mal auf zahlen der
gewalt in uns zügen bei der deutschen
bahn 1,8 millionen in die 18 passagiere
hat die bahn im jahr 1,8 milliarden
beförderten passagiere im jahr 220 bei
der bahn im jahr 219 waren es 2,9
milliarden passagiere und klar wegen
corona zuletzt ein bisschen weniger
bahnpassagiere
und doch wir machen einmal die nächste
grafik dazu fast 20.000 gewaltdelikte
auf bahnhöfen und in zügen fast genauso
viel wie in den jahren zuvor im selben
jahr kam es zu
2070 angriffen auf bahnmitarbeiter 215
heißt es waren es nur in
anführungsstrichen
1876 fällen also tatort bahn tatort zug
wir wollen darüber diskutieren ob wir
nicht dieselben sicherheitsvorkehrungen
bei der bahn in den zügen brauchen wie
im flugzeug und zugeschaltet ist so dazu
der stellvertretende bundesvorsitzende
der deutschen polizeigewerkschaft und
chef der bundespolizeigewerkschaft heiko
teggatz schönen guten tag hat es
ist die deutsche bahn gemessen an
flugzeugen ja gefährlicher sozusagen
aufgrund fehlender
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
sie können die sich als maßnahmen nicht
gleich durchsetzen wie auf einem
flughafen
mit einer unheimlichen logistik
verbunden wenn man alle bahnhöfe und
alle zu steigenden passagiere so
kontrollieren würde wie wenn sie in
einem flugzeug einsteigen insofern ist
hier präsenz der polizei gefragt ich
denke durch präsenz auf den bahnhöfen
und in den zügen von der bundespolizei
werde eine oder andere täter abgehalten
davon solche schrecklichen taten
zugegeben
ganz konkret was glauben sie was wäre
anders gelaufen während da am wochenende
polizeibeamte mit im zug gewesen
nun uniformierte kolleginnen und
kollegen mit dem zug sind jetzt von der
bundespolizei oder von der landespolizei
dann entsteht den reisenden gegen
überauchen gewissen gewissen gewissen
sicherheits eindruck und
straftäter in den zügen überlegen sich
dreimal ob sie entweder taschendiebstahl
delikt begehen
er hat er ganz ganz kurzes die leitung
ist das bild eingefroren jetzt kann ich
sie wieder auch bewegt sehen und hören
hat der cas noch einmal um das
auszuführen also in diesem fall hatten
wir hatten die passagiere ja sozusagen
glück da war privat eine
bundespolizistin unterwegs in dem zug
aber sollten wir das nicht
institutionalisieren also immer in zügen
sowie es in flugzeugen eben auch so
häufig der fall ist sozusagen sky
marshalls für die bahn schaffen
ja ich hoffe dass die neue
bundesregierung an der einstellung
offensive der bundespolizei festhält und
auch weiter die starken
einstellungszahlen hält denn nur mit
mehr und viel personal wir haben wir in
der lage sein überhaupt die notwendige
präsenz aufzubringen momentan ist die
bundespolizei personell noch nicht so
aufgestellt dass wir also lücken büros
präsenz in den zügen zeigen können also
da braucht es einfach auch mehr personal
was ist denn ihr rat an die menschen die
in der bahn sitzen und in so eine
seltene situation aber kommen was macht
man da am besten zieht die notbremse man
holt hilfe wie soll man sich da
verhalten naja also zunächst einmal
sollte man auf gar keinen fall den
helden spielen wenn man nicht beruflich
mit solchen situationen zu tun hat wie
die kollegen hält gott sei dank hatte
des weiteren sollte man zusehen dass man
sich möglichst rasch aus dem
gefahrenbereich heraus gibt die
notbremse ziehen das immer so eine sache
ist also wenn der zug dann auf freier
strecke still steht dann ist das für
polizei auch schwierig kräfte in den zug
zu bringen also von den roten also würde
ich in dem fall abraten wichtig nicht
den helden spielen und sich aus dem
gefahrenbereich gegeben und sollte es
kontrollen geben also er jetzt in jedem
zug die sind ja auch lange polizei mit
fahren muss sollte es kontrollen an den
bahnhöfen geben bisher kann man ja ja
völlig unbeobachtet und unkontrolliert
eben die züge besteigen mit allem was
man halt so dabei hat
ja so in anderen europäischen ländern
ist das also wenn sie in london oder in
frankreich in die öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel steigenden haben diese
einlasskontrollen in die bahnhöfe rein
weil das wäre denkbar da sind aber
sowohl die sicherheitsbehörden als auch
die deutsche bahn ag gefragt ihr konzept
auf den tisch zu legen um so was in
naher zukunft dann umzusetzen
danke heiko teggatz chef der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft nach dieser
messerattacke im ece am samstag und
folgen daraus vielen dank